I'm here to talk about a domain-specific
language called P that we design
together with our colleagues chaska deer
and ethan jackson in microsoft research
in redmond and some partners in the
windows product group as you know
operating systems like Windows have
several highly asynchronous and
concurrent components and designing them
in a bug free manner is extremely
difficult what we did in this project
was that we came up with a
domain-specific notation where
concurrent state machines can be written
down you could think about it in a
pictorial like notation and we can do
two things with this notation using
these state machines we can do
verification or model checking at the
level of the design and then find bugs
at design time the second thing we can
do is that we can compile the state
machines the actual running code that
runs inside the OS we use this
methodology to design the USB 3.0 in
Windows 8 and the product group used our
tools to do verification as well as code
generation and the actual driver stack
that ships with windows 8 and later uses
the results of research work you can
also read about our work in this paper p
safe asynchronous event when programming
that we published in pldi 2030